con la llegada de omicron a américa
latina se endurecen las medidas a los
viajeros
brasil el primer país de la región en
detectar la nueva variante restringir a
la entrada de seis países africanos
entre ellos botsuana estonia lesoto
namibia zimbabwe y sudáfrica una
determinación similar fue notificada por
el ministerio de salud paraguayo quien
también prohibió el ingreso de viajeros
de suazilandia y mozambique y angola al
igual que guatemala que veto la llegada
de personas provenientes de algunas
zonas del sur de áfrica al igual que
desde egipto también el presidente
ecuatoriano guillermo la sub comunicó
que cerrara sus fronteras para 8 países
africanos visión de entrado al
territorio nacional a toda persona cuyo
punto de origen escala o tránsito sea la
lista específica de países del áfrica
que serán publicados por las autoridades
competentes
otro tipo de medidas también han sido
tomadas por las naciones
latinoamericanas como argentina y panamá
argentina determinó que los pasajeros
que ingresen al país desde áfrica
deberán hacer una cuarentena también
deberán contar con un esquema de
vacunación completo y con una prueba pcr
negativa panamá decretó un aislamiento
obligatorio de 14 días para los viajeros
las medidas podrán extenderse en otros
países ante el aumento de casos de
omicron en la región
y cuando las autoridades japonesas
anunciaron este miércoles que detectaron
un caso de la variante en un pasajero
que despegó desde perú